Goodfellas great Ray Liotta Ray honored
today by his loved ones and former
co-stars with a posthumous star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame
if you build it he will come I mean he
knew he was going to get it before he
passed so and I know it was a huge honor
for him and I know it was definitely
very special to him and it was a
Monumental moment in his career Carson
Leota accepted the star on her father's
behalf alongside his fiancee JC and
former Blackbird co-star Taryn Edgerton
as well as Elizabeth Banks who directed
Leota in cocaine beer out now after he
read the script Ray asked me for more
jokes he was like everybody's got funny
lines I want to be quirkier I always
admired his acting but I genuinely
enjoyed him as a human when I first met
Ray I was
frankly a bit scared of him I've been
trying to figure out how to approach him
when he saw me
headed straight for me and hugged me
without saying a word everyone deserves
a ray in their life thank you
that star and his work will live on
forever
[Music]